[Música]
conocí a pedro hace dos años en un
pueblito que se llama agua caliente o
algas
pero tenía la opinión
como una pasa tan pequeñitas que ni
siquiera podía orinar
era víctima de una enfermedad de los
riñones que ya era absolutamente
irreversible y ese día me contó que lo
estaba esperando un trasplante
lo volví a ver hace dos años
y me contó que le habían hecho los dos
transplantes de riñón y habían hecho dos
por uno
y el otro había sido de un cuerpo que
había muerto había fallecido y se lo
habían dado y ninguno de los dos riñones
su cuerpo lo había recibido de la manera
en la que
esperaba y entonces ahora los doctores
lo mandan tres veces por semana san jose
a que se cambie toda la sangre del
cuerpo
imagínense lo que es venir desde agua
caliente lo hagas es que es un pueblo
donde básicamente el viento se devuelve
del asfalto no llega llegar hasta el ya
que lo conectan a una máquina de
hemodiálisis
nosotros publicamos la historia de peor
en julio de este año
contamos en esa historia que él no está
solo hay más hay más de 1200
guanacastecos en este momento que la
padecen hay 2000 guanacastecos que han
muerto por esta enfermedad
y la razón por la cual han muerto es
porque ellos han trabajado durante años
bajo el sol arduo de guanacaste y piensa
en el solar 250 casas pues ustedes en
algún momento han ido saben lo que es
pues resulta que
pedro está entre estas personas que
trabajaron muchos años bajo el sol y
esta experiencia para ellos ha sido
devastadora porque es todo un pueblo
enfermo vos vas a clientes hagas esto
que es cualquier puerta y en cualquiera
de ellas hay una persona con esta
enfermedad
resulta que esta enfermedad se
desarrolla y lo han sabido durante años
los científicos no solamente por la
exposición al sol sino también por la
exposición agroquímicos continua y
sistemática
nosotros cuando publicamos esta historia
la verdad es que bueno ustedes ya saben
yo soy periodista y por supuesto que no
vine a hablarles aquí solo de enfermedad
renal crónica porque no soy médica sino
que vengo a contarles cómo ser
periodista de alguna forma me ha cultivo
yo me siento eso es un poco como
frustrada de que el periodismo como que
no cambia en realidad es no pública y
pública y no pasa nada no no no cambian
las cosas
el periodismo es justamente cómo voy a
hacerlo es una metáfora les voy a contar
una infidencia y es que se acabaron los
clickers entonces la presentación no va
a pasar pero yo les voy a dar a matizar
xxi
el periodismo es más o menos como el
volibol imagínense lo así nosotros somos
como los como los que llegan y no lean
ahora lo más alto posible para que
alguien más llegue y la demanda
pero si nadie remata esa pelota no hay
punto en periodismo si nadie llega a
rematar la pelota no hay cambio
y eso es justamente el poder del que
vengo hablarles hoy es el poder de un
clic
el poder que en este momento tienen
ustedes en las manos probablemente todos
al menos a los que puedo ver con el
celular de compartir las historias que
realmente merecen ser escuchados
si bien es cierto el periodo y uno no
puede cambiar realidades como ustedes
con todos ustedes es la única forma que
nosotros tenemos de realmente demostrar
que esto puede de que de que el
periodismo pueda demostrar que puede
haber un cambio y estos tienen medios de
comunicación como la voz de buena casa
el la dónde conacaste nosotros hemos
contado por ejemplo como las mujeres son
violentadas y son las mujeres de
guanacaste son las más violentas de todo
el país también hemos contado la
historia de una pareja de una pareja
sexualmente diversa y como han vivido su
realidad en una provincia absolutamente
conservadora y hemos contado también
como las cicatrices de diferentes tipos
de agroquímicos han dejado marcas
indelebles en el cuerpo de las personas
hemos contado la historia de un azul y
por ejemplo a quien le operaron de un
seno y entonces no hay forma de que esta
mujer no pueda hacer un ejemplo para
nosotros y para para contarme toda esta
realidad esas cosas nosotros nos
retratamos las ponemos en el periódico
y al preguntarles ahora que los veo con
el celular y la mano también qué tipo de
contenidos comparten ustedes sexualmente
en facebook en twitter en youtube bueno
usualmente en facebook hizo un estudio y
se dieron cuenta de que al menos todas
las personas comparten una vez a la
semana algún contenido y usualmente lo
que comparten es
vídeos de gatitos faldas que soy yo
y una al contenido que espalda es muy
político o muy emocional o de pronto que
les va a generar mucha crítica
eso es eso es lo normal de todos los
días yo no digo que esté mal pero algo
cambió cuando nosotros decidimos
compartir la historia de pedro y de los
niños de cuántas tecos que que viven con
enfermedad renal crónica y es que más de
2500 personas decidieron compartir esta
historia y eso hizo género una cadena de
personas y de almas que llegaron hasta
las autoridades del gobierno y llegaron
también hacia hasta médicos y abogados
que todos los días ni una recta ni
correo diciéndome una sola cosa
como podemos hacer para ayudar a estas
personas qué hacemos cómo les ayudamos a
ustedes
y así es justamente lo que yo les quiero
escribir hoy es que ustedes tienen todo
el poder nosotros desde la voz de
guanacaste nos comprometemos a seguir
contando las historias que merecen ser
escuchadas lo que necesitamos de ustedes
es que se atrevan a rematar la pelota
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]